uh one semifinal is already in the books
and the Indiana Pacers knocked out their
uh Central Division Rivals the Milwaukee
Bucks today pulling away it was a
one-point game there late 113 112 and
then the Pacers pull away uh behind to
the surprise of no one Tyrese halberton
who joins us here along with his pops
John it's good to see you sir uh put the
mic up here so we can we can hear you
too I mean what we'll get to plenty with
you Tyrese
but I know you guys don't miss many
games and I know Brenda mom has only
missed one at Iowa State but she's there
all the time so what was it like to
watch this unfold today in Vegas for you
Dad I'm real I just love it you just to
be there to watch my son do what he does
and enjoy it with a smile can't get in
better than that it does not get much
better than the way you guys are playing
right now Tyrese and I know you come in
with a lot of belief in your team and
was that was that belief shaken at all
because after you had a double ditchit
lead third quarter here they come they
take the lead back but you guys never
blanked yeah you know we played them
earlier in the year same exact situation
for us we were up 20 in the first
quarter they came back went Zone we able
to get back in the game Giannis had like
50 so um you know we knew was a game of
runs we knew they'd have their you know
one of theirs but uh we knew we'd
respond the right way I we don't really
get to see you play a lot it was a Jo
watching today I came in in the green
room and I told Kenny I said Kenny Trey
is the real deal question you remind me
of so Ty I mean tyres excuse me you
remind me of Ernie it ain't me it's that
damn cannabis behind
me that cannabis behind got me anyway
you remind me of a old school new school
player
like who taught you how to play the
right way cuz I was watching like I was
really watching like you make the right
play every time who taught you how to
play like that him
him um you know my teachers growing up
coach Shady coach Weber uh Coach B just
my coaches growing up and uh the amount
of '90s magic film this guy has made me
watch in my life is ridiculous so um you
know I think that that that plays a lot
into it as well such a joy to watch
congratulations yeah congratulations you
you're going to get either you know the
Lakers or the New Orleans in the next
round we don't care you know I'm just
I'm not saying he does cuz I already
know he knows what time it is I already
saw that so for me you know I had said
the other night that you were my
favorite player now to watch I
appreciate that I said that because
there's two things that make a great
basketball player Ernie and and everyone
is to me is that everyone does the same
amount of jump ropes lift weights the
same it's the decisions that separates
greatness from good good from average
your decisions what is your approach to
the game to be able to get 15 points I
mean 15 assists 27 points and being able
to share the world have the world and no
turnovers but it's it's all about
decisions what makes LeBron the greatest
player in the world that ever played
possibly behind one guy named Jordan is
his decisions that he makes yeah I think
just uh diving into film diving into
film you know paying attention asking
the questions one thing I've been taught
my whole life is there's no such thing
as a stupid question so just trying to
ask as much as I can and learn as much
as I can I got great teachers growing up
I got one of the greatest coaches of all
time coaching me right now um and I got
you know great minds around me every day
so I just just enjoy picking their
brains and and learning from them every
day you said something interesting
earlier you said you know we played them
early in the year we were up 20 they
probably realized like we can't play
these gu on guys oneon-one so they
switched to a zone so it was pretty even
game then they switched to the Zone
later in the third quarter this time
what flip how much did y'all talk about
that before the game they're like these
guys going to go to a zone at some point
yeah we talked about it a lot because
really since we played them last they
haven't really played play in he Zone
they've moved to playing Brook more
traditionally in a drop which is what
he's accustomed to and that's worked for
them but we knew the way we play up and
down they were going to have to go Zone
to to to to change the game but it was
interesting cuz most people play zone to
get you outside of the middle they
forced me every to the middle every
possession so that allowed me to pass
and get guys involved and we didn't make
as many shots as we normally do tonight
uh we make some more shots the game's a
little different but uh we dug in
figured it out Andrew nard uh Bruce
Brown made some big shots in the middle
of that zone you know Underdog gave me
stat this the first game y'all won this
year where y'all didn't make double
digit threes y'all only made Seven
really this the first game this year
that y'all won and y'all didn't make at
least 10 threes wow that's crazy W hey
let me let me ask you guys John and
Tyrese both
about growing up learning the game
teaching the
game what you expected out of your son
what the how did what was that Dynamic
like we'll start with you John it was
easy tyres have always been the type of
kid that you didn't really have to push
him because he had the desire from
inside and he wanted to play so all you
had to do is just direct him let him do
his thing simple as that and what and
what are your memories of what your dad
had to teach you yeah I think uh my my
household growing up was very
interesting it was good cop bad cop and
usually the the the dad is the bad cop
but this guy never never hates on me
ever he always shows me love he don't
ever have a bad thing to say about me
it's my mom who goes to all the games
she she has to play bad cop more more
times than not uh but uh it's
interesting Dynamic and they've done a
great job in helping me learn the game
for sure tyres we talked earlier on the
show on how I thought that Zion in this
game should say you know what this it's
my time now it's my era so my question
to you is when you see guys that are
perceived better than you how does that
make you feeling what's your mindset
going into a game like a Dame l or
Giannis and you know you are who you are
but those guys will proceed a little
higher like what's your mindset when you
playing against those guys uh just
compete compete regardless I mean
there's some of the greatest basketball
players in the world I mean all the
greatest basketball players in the world
they in this league right now some of
the greatest players ever are in this
league right now so um I'm just coming
out here to compete on a nightly basis
and be ready he's such a nice kid yeah
because that's the wrong answer yeah it
is because supposed to go get them it it
had to be message when you point when
you look at their wrist that is that is
that's a message that the world knows
what that means and I was I saw you say
I do this too if you if you if you do
that and wave goodbye you would have
said everything cuz he waves goodbye or
he shot those shot so it is like I
remember
Shaq played against you and he was like
no this is my I am the man now are you
saying I'm part of this Elite company
are you saying that oh for sure for sure
no question I'm a competitor hold on
hold on Kenny he ain't got to say it
look at the drip look at the
drip they put we put our pants on just
to save so come on come time I'm ready
to check up ready to go where's your mom
at she's right there there come on Mom
come on no come on the state come on
now you got to
say come there you go thank you Brenda
we appreciate you being here say hi good
to see you how you awesome yeah
nice to see you and let me let me ask
you this cuz John you're still you're
still calling games you're still reing
games right I am now tyres when you
knowing how difficult a job that is and
how thankless a job that is does that
make you a little more understanding of
those who officiate your games not
really not really I mean he's a terrible
ref don't let him laugh we got into it
last night he's a terrible ref so no not
really it doesn't really help at all to
be honesty it's been it's been great
great having the halberton join us here
live in Las Vegas again well played man
you're just you're at the top of your
game and you're in
the it wasn't me it's the Cannabis yes
he did I did it's that cannabis it's
legal here by the
way oh that's awesome right
there hey it ain't me we appreciate you
joining us good luck Saturday against
whoever you play whether
be I got
five I got five on
it